female orgasm
that gasm baby
that uh that betty bust you know what
i'm talking about
um says female emission that orgasm
you know these are talking about women
this uh those gunners baby you know them
ejaculators some women they'll damn
you know what i'm saying they could
really uh
they really
you know they got that
that freaking uh
they got that
that cooter gleek you know what i'm
talking about these women are squirters
they call them gunners i don't like
using that kind of language but they're
real gunners baby
you know what i'm saying they'll damn uh
they got that bidet just built into
their bada you know
but dussy you know what i'm talking
about they just
um
you know the damn
they could wash off the back of a moth
at probably [__] eight feet
but the female emission at orgasm
uh is confirmed in a new study
that uh the fluid
that is released is from the bladder
there's long been a lot of chatter over
the years um that it was you know female
you know they had like a special
you know s you know semen pocket in them
or something i don't know
but uh
or that it was tears like a lot of women
you know have a lot of tears built up in
them and then they just gun out all
these tears at you
but
a lot of us knew that it was urine
i mean
it was urine and so there's a new study
that was done if you haven't heard about
this
and this is uh the international journal
of urology
um
it says five women two in their thirties
two in their forties and one in their
fifties dang baby
dang
grandma got that super soca
they participated in this study
all women were able to
uh squirt they was these gunners
and three of them
gunned out
uh
with sexual stimulation
and two of them with penetrative sexual
stimulation
so one of them was just kind of reading
the braille or two of them were just
reading the braille and the other one
was
and the other three were using the
pencil
um
and what they did was they injected the
women with a blue dye into their
bladders so they they could tell what
what was what oh they drained them first
it says
a catheter was inserted before sexual
stimulation and the bladder was emptied
so they drained these babes
and then a mixture of indigo
and saline was injected into the bladder
[Music]
sexual stimulation was provided
and it was videotaped and verified some
perv out there running this deal
and uh
the secretions were collected in sterile
cups and it was found the main component
of
squirt fluid
is urine urine
so there you go we knew it was a piss i
say piss or pp but i say piss also
mostly
uh we knew it was piss and it is
if you didn't think it was pizz i think
you're a real cr you
you knew it was piss it was peace so
anyway
um
yeah that's what women have been doing
they've been pissing
uh secret that's really a secret it's a
top you know it's a real
it's that backup bladder though damn
when you got that
that thing or really somebody can water
a plant you know or just dampen a
you know dampen a damn uh
i knew this one gal she could dampen
probably a eighth of a loaf of
pepperidge farm bro this [__] really
had that
she had that baby hose backed up in her
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one